hello we're glad you've joined us for
this live webinar optimizing
antimicrobial stewardship for patients
with chronic obstructive pulmonary
disease within the VA health system i am
michelle ashton of laberd's
and i'll be moderating this session
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab routes the leading
scientific social networking website and
provider of virtual events and webinars
advancing scientific collaboration and
learning it's brought to you at
biomerieux a world leader in the field
of in vitro diagnostics for more than 55
years the Oh Mary U is present in 43
countries and serves more than 160
countries with the support of a large
network of distributors CEO Mary u
provides diagnostic solutions systems
reagents software and services which
help determine the source of disease and
contamination to improve patient health
and ensure consumer safety if products
are mainly used for diagnosing
infectious diseases and some critical
illnesses the company's diagnostic
solutions are also used for detecting
microorganisms and agri-food
pharmaceutical and cosmetic products to
learn more please visit
www.gfi.com/webmonitor screen labeled
ask a question and click on the send
button questions will be answered after
this presentation to enlarge the slide
window click on the arrows at the top
right hand corner of the presentation
window if you experience technical
problems seeing or hearing the
presentation just click on the support
tab found at the top right of the
presentation window or report your
problems by typing it into the ask a
question box located on the far left of
your screen this is an educational
webinar and thus offers free continuing
education credits
we click on the continuing education
credits tab located at the top right of
the presentation window and follow the
process to obtain your credits
I now present today's speaker dr.
Devendra Annan medical director of
critical care services medical surgical
ICU neurocritical care ICU at Morton
plant hospital and Clearwater Florida to
learn more about our speaker please
click on the biography tab at the top of
your screen doctoral men you may now
begin your presentation thank you very
much introduction Michele thank you all
for standing into it I think is a pretty
important aspect of managing patients
with copd which in your patient
population is a significant proportion
of patients you deal with daily
Huell disclosures biomerieux is
sponsoring this presentation when the
objectives of the talker to assess the
burden of COPD and acute exacerbations
review the efficacy of highly multiplex
respiratory panel review the data on
antibiotic search of the procalcitonin
and how they really impact in optimizing
antibiotic exposure for acute
exacerbations of COPD I start with a
case presentation the 69 year old male
smoker presents with coughing congestion
transyl breast and a little range here
for about 10 days creases clear sputum
historically his wife and grandchild
also had been sick with similar symptoms
of the previous week here the patient's
past medical history - given by
hypertension coronary disease congestive
heart failure diabetes and obstructive
sleep apnea not an atypical patient for
the VA the receive a 99.5 occasional
basal crackles on auscultation
saturations alert 90% on room air and
white count nonspecific initial
procaster 10.2 now at 5:00 a.m. in the
morning and then chest x-ray chor patchy
bilateral airspace disease as you can
see there's also some flattening of the
diaphragm suggestive of obstructive
Airways disease and some hyper mild
hyperinflation
the question is would you sought
antibiotics at this point given the
informations you have in the picture
that you have
and then further information the
respiratory viral panel came back
positive for human metapneumovirus by
about 9:00 a.m. that day and then the
PCT came back on day two and 0.15 low
and then the next question would be
would you stop antibiotics given this
information on day two at that point in
time sputum and blood cultures were
negative and pending for the blood
cultures still
you think about that
so what's up with COPD in the cubix a
sebacean the acute respiratory tract
infection preaches high disease burden
in adults and children it's the third
most common cause of death worldwide the
respiratory virus is accounts of fifty
to sixty six percent of respiratory
tract infections depending on the source
of the literature rapid identification
has the potential to reduce antibiotic
exposure initiate appropriate antiviral
therapy where needed and reducing
hospital admissions possibly releasing
negative stay and allows to appropriate
infection control measures to take place
so going back cigarette smoking with
glamorize in the 40s 50s 60s is going to
with these adverts for cigarettes as
Christmas presents
positions historically the cowboy
lifestyle but by the 1990s things are
beginning to change in secondhand smoke
and cigarette smoking in general is felt
to be a bigger problem and probably not
good
there's not just cigarettes that also
the burning of biomass fuels and closed
environments also produces a similar
syndrome chronic autoimmune disease in
patients who don't smoke but are exposed
to this kind of particulate pollution in
closed spaces and of course in open
spaces with high particulate smog areas
for COPD came out in the late 1980s and
his primary function was to produce a
non-biased review of the current
evidence or assessment diagnosis and
treatment of page with COPD and to
highlight short term and long term
treatment objectives organized into two
groups one in relieving and reducing the
impact of symptoms and secondarily to
reduce the risk of adverse health events
that may affect patient in the future
because symptom assessment and health
status management the COPD is the fourth
leading cause of death in the world
projected and becomes the third leading
cause by 2020 and more than three
million people died of COPD in 2012
attempt to fix ascent of older probably
the COPD burden is projected to increase
in coming decades because of continued
explosion of COPD risk factors to see if
any risk factors and aging of the
population
it's a major public health problem
producing some sixteen point three
million offices as the Year in the
United States and about six hundred
thirty two thousand hospitalizations
this is data from 2007 on average more
people die daily from COPD than diabetes
of breast cancer about three hundred
forty one third day from COPD
the copd is that commonly is a common
preventable and treatable disease that
is characterized by persistent repertory
symptoms therefore the mutation that is
due to airway and or alveolar atomizer
is usually closed are significant
exposure to noxious particles or gases
the SIPP pathology and by pathology as
you can see that smoking or pollution
produces inflammation impaired lung
growth etc decline in lung function
which infer the lung injury and their
systemic inflammatory consequences
pathology occurs in the small Airways
producing emphasized modest changes
systemic effects and then there's
persistent airflow limitation sometimes
variable but more often six as the
disease progresses and the clinical
manifestations are shortness of breath
made worse of exacerbations and with
other comorbidities such as
cardiovascular diseases
this is a diagram of how pulmonary
function progresses over time in the
Greenline normal people without COPD
will see a slow decline of one to two
percent a year in the fev1
this is forced expiratory volume in one
second on the simple spirometry in the
red line if you have a COPD history
smoking history you can see a fairly
dramatic decline in lung function sed
won over a period of time and then the
yellow graph the patients with small
lungs with no COPD is in parallel in
decline to the Green Line but the black
line would be small lungs with COPD we
see a equally dramatic drop in sed one
as time goes on
in general if you stop smoking it takes
about 10 to 15 years to get back to the
same rate of decline as if you had been
a nonsmoker so it takes a long time for
the effects of effects some lung
function to go away having stopped
smoking
common rescue terrariums with insurance
and breath of and Austrian production
and these centers are often under
reported by patients especially shorts
of breath as they tend to reduce their
activity level to compensate pradesh
ones abreast so they'll often deny being
short of breath but a spouse will tell
you that or a partner will tell you that
the patients are actually slowing down
maybe not doing as much in when exerted
will get short of breath
the main researchers who said is tobacco
smoking but other environment exposures
such as biomass fuel exposure and air
pollution
contribute
there's a chronic inflammatory process
developing which then produces M percent
structural changes is produced the
emphysema the pathogenesis is from
excessive oxidative stress the protease
and approaches imbalance develops
promoting more inflammatory cell
promotion within the lungs accumulation
within the lungs and the tissue with
inflammatory mediators in peri
bronchiole and interstitial fibrosis
developing in the periphery of the lung
they're looking at samples from
Washington patients with non-smokers and
during exacerbations what you see is
increased in neutrophils as well as an
increase in eosinophils so it can be an
inflammatory and or infectious etiology
as you can see in patients with acute
exacerbation compared to baseline and
compared to non-smokers
it's a multi-component
using a combination of the axillary
dysfunction the mucociliary escalator
stops working you could accumulate
producing structural changes the
information that's developing around the
airways and small Airways produces
airflow limitation this is some systemic
component to disease including cachexia
loss of weight and in certain group of
patients the classically the pink puffy
type at the semblance patients unlike
the blue bloated a large patient often
overweight and but with significant
metabolic abnormalities associated with
this disease
to the diagnosis key factors for
considering a diagnosis of progressive
symptoms over time versus exercise
system or persistent unlike as well
they'll reverse the normal to be a
chronic chronic cough oftentimes with
sputum sometimes without and recurrent
episodes of wheezing from obstruction
chronic student production can occur and
suggestive of COPD and recurrent or
propensity for recurrent lower
respiratory tract infections as well
there are post factors genetic factors
as well which are implicated tobacco
smokers we fed and from biomass fuels
and occupational exposure to dust vapors
and fumes in industrial context as well
is often a family history of COPD and
the childhood factors of childhood
exposure to smoke which can actually in
pregnant females can produce low birth
weight childhood and respiratory
infections and recurrent exposures a
child to smoke in tobacco pollution this
is a classic chest x-ray of a emphysema
wrist patient you can see the long lungs
and see the very flattened diaphragm and
the saber
she's trachea straight
and the barrel shape chest further down
there
you
simple spirometry is adequate for
screening and what you see here on the
left-hand panel is the fev1 being mobile
at about 4 liters as the forced
expiratory volume in one second at four
liters - towards vital capacity that's a
total amount exhaled over six seconds at
being five meters in the ratio the - is
about point eight which is normal on the
right hand side you see the fev1 reduced
at 1.8 liters the forced vital capacity
over six seconds at 3.2 liter spending
reduced from normal but even more
reduces the ratio between fev1 FBC at
point five six which is indicative of
significant obstruction to air flow
the gold classification in patients who
have you reduced fev1 FBC of less than
0.7 if the fev1 is greater than 80% of
predicted normal but they still have
mild COPD as that ratio is less than 0.7
if they have an sed one between 50% and
80% they have moderate disease so their
disease will be between 30 and 50%
predicted and very severe disease gold
for for being sed one of less than 30%
of predicted
the differential diagnosis is
significant so everybody not everybody
is short of breath and wheezing has COPD
so asthma CHF can produce what we call
cardiac asthma symptoms or wheezing from
congestion bronchiectasis tuberculosis
ability bronchiolitis and diffuse tank
bronchiolitis can all produce very
similar symptoms and oftentimes minimal
chest x-ray changes
the exacerbation maintenance therapy
preventing exacerbation is key for good
health and prolongation of maintaining
pulmonary function testing these
patients of course number one is station
of smoking or exposure to the pollution
correct inhaler technique is very
important to teach the patients to use
their inhalers correctly appropriate use
of bronchodilators on a regular basis
and PRM basis depending on the severity
of disease getting vaccinated
pneumococcal vaccine and this Samiha the
flu vaccine boomer rehab has been shown
to improve functionality not pulmonary
function testing with sandy
functionality with appropriate pulmonary
rehabilitation and oxygen therapy in
those patients who desaturate at night
or with exertion is very important to
help reduce the progression of disease
and in a very severe patients who have
severe nocturnal D saturation and
hypercarbia potential of CO 2
non-invasive positive pressure
ventilation has been shown to improve
outcomes
not going to go through the medications
that are used in COPD now there's been a
large increase in the number combination
but certainly the basic medications
remain the same but short-acting
bronchodilators beta agonists
long-acting beta agonist Oh lovers
you've got the short acting and
long-acting antimuscarinic llamas and
then you have the inhaled
corticosteroids long and short acting
and a combination thereof so baseline is
treatment with short-acting
bronchodilators a butyl for acute
exacerbations maintenance therapy is
long-acting beta agonists and
antibiotics anticholinergics and then
the use of steroid in health steroids
invasions have excessive asians and to
prevent exacerbation
as you can see the inhaled
corticosteroids long acting background
is lava as well as oral glucocorticoids
or class evasions the PDE for inhibitors
such as rock luma last for very severe
patients with end-stage disease the use
of antibiotics for prophylaxis one major
study alfred study Newman journal in
2011 showed that daily use of mr. myson
at 250 a day certainly reduced the
incidents of exacerbations from I
believe about 1.8 accessories in here
down to 1.4 a significant it did improve
the quality of life but there was a cost
to this with deafness and with patients
who had QT interval prolongation this
was a problem and the overall cost
financially was about a thousand dollars
a year I think the study would have been
better if they dosed this at maybe three
times a week because we know the levels
accumulate and become very high with a
system icing has it's used for short
course treatments that would have been a
most appropriate study not just for the
anti infected but also for the
anti-inflammatory effects of a system
Ison in COPD patients and lastly they
see mucolytics and NSSL cysteine and
Culver City to help expectorate and
clear that flame which is often causing
obstruction in the airway
the neck sensation is a major problem
that occurs and also often causes a
significant reduction in function as a
stepwise faction stepwise fashion with
every accessor Batian patients have a
decrease in their pulmonary function and
capabilities and they never get back to
where they were so the conservation is
defined as an acute worsening of
respiratory symptoms that result in
additional therapy in black there you
see the classic Antonis and criteria
from 87 1987 and the type 1 exacerbation
was defined by the presence of increased
breathlessness beautifully mimic
peerless type 2 by the presence of two
these symptoms in type 3 by the presence
of one of these symptoms in addition to
one of the following a per se tract
infection the past five days fever that
any other cause increased wheezing I'll
call for an increase in heart rate or
receipt rate by 20% compared to baseline
and that has stood the test of time
excessive patience of COPD can be
precipitated by several factors again
cigarette smoke pollution infection and
the goal for treatment is to minimize
the negative impact of current
exacerbations in subsequent events so
Ernie ratted recognition of an
exacerbation and intervention helps
reduce morbidity there are host factors
involved infection produces 50 to 70
percent of the exacerbations and
depending on the study in viruses
produced between 20 and 40 percent that
percentage is going up over time as
their ability to diagnose rare
infections has become more accurate and
complete with the respiratory viral
panels that will get into bacteria so
implicated about 50 percent of patients
it's interesting oftentimes these
patients with COPD are colonized with
bacteria but it's not the colonizing
bacteria that causes the exacerbations
is usually a new strain that produces
that looking at the recent research
environmental factors play about 10% and
that is the sulfur dioxide nitric oxide
nitrous oxides and ozone producing
significant burden on the log when in
high levels atmospherically there's an
increased inflammatory burden and
accelerated decline in function the in
hospital mortality rate kid
exacerbations between 8 and 11 percent
and the one-year mortality is 20 to 20
so there should be twenty to forty three
percent thirty three percent I'm sorry
in one year mortality in patients who've
had an acute exacerbation in the
previous year it's a very significant
implication there
in this study out of thorax the European
study looked at the distribution of
causes of COPD and some 30 percent were
unknown 25 percent were
combination of bacterial and viral and
then the rest as you can see broken down
into bacteria and viruses
and similar proportions depending on
where you are in the world as we'll see
and again you see the inflammatory
changes there with eosinophils in some
patients or neutrophils and others in
exacerbation
so neutrophils tend to be higher a
bacterial infection is Senators more an
inflammatory inflammation where
precipitating that exacerbation
this study out of the UK looked at
c-reactive protein levels in microbial
etiology and patients hospitalized of
the Dudek laceration of COPD there's a
264 patients of exacerbations of COPD
and 26% tested positive for respiratory
viruses only 13% had bacteria only in
12% a big spiral bacterial detection and
49% had no pathogens detected CRP level
in temperature were strongly associated
with viral detection rate significantly
as you can see which is different from
other studies so in here you can see the
mix of unknown viral bacterial mix viral
bacterial on the left-hand side and the
breakdown on the right-hand side of
various pathogens mostly viral and some
bacterial as you can see
and then if you look at this time of
looking at CRP levels were very low in
the bacteria and high in the virus only
and if you look at the temperature also
not very high in the bacterium at higher
in the viral you know this is different
from many other studies looking at this
and which looked at bacterias being a
major cause of elevation in CRP and this
study again shows how the positive
patients with CRP influenza virus was
right thousand taking of the influence
CRP levels compared to the lower panel
where the pneumonia patients with strep
pneumonia that levels are higher but the
percentage of patients learning about 6%
to patients with a high CRP compared to
the viral which is up to 25% to patients
you
study detection rate and respiratory
viruses and hustlaz patients when the
kid exacerbation was strongly associated
with host inflammatory response as
measured by CRP and fever reinforcing
evidence to supporting that respiratory
viruses initiated a proportion of acute
exacerbations and that using this would
help guide viral testing and direct
antiviral therapy suddenly the numbers
show that a significant number virus is
at present but whether CRP is helpful or
not it's unclear from this this study
out of Japan more conventional looking
at a surgeon's and severe exacerbations
identified by real-time PCR plus older
methods which included CRP and
interestingly here viruses were only
with 20% mixed was about 18 bacteria
only 48% a slightly different mix there
but in this situation what we saw was
what they saw was that the TRP group was
significantly higher in the patients
with bacterial infections and lower in
the viral infection so different from
that previous study the CF is very
nonspecific can be up or down in viral
infections not very helpful in acute
exacerbation COPD in general however the
benefits of real-time PCR identification
suggested a higher number of patients
were identified with viruses so almost
90 percent of the patients had some
diagnosis or some presence of a
bacterium virus so increased viral
pathogen pick up from 20 to 32 percent
see if it exacerbates from gram-negative
enteric or non fermenting pathogens
predicted long hospitalization such as
Pseudomonas and CRP associated with
battery charge for acute exacerbations
of COPD
this study looked at the effect of
implementing the respiratory viral panel
on antibiotic prescription patents that
discharged an adult mitad with mild to
moderate the kids exacerbation this is a
retrospective before and after study
looking at the winter period from
January to March between 2013 and 2016
and the primary outcome was antibiotic
prescriptions that discharged enrolled
some 232 patients which 133 following
the RVP introduction and the mean age
was comparable in both groups the
patients in the pre rup group was
similar to the first IVP group for most
characteristics
difficut reduction in antibiotic
prescription rate at discharge in
patient admitted with acute
exacerbations after introduction of EP
or respiratory viral panel every sim
percent down to sixty three point two
percent with a p-value point zero one in
adjusted analyses patients in the pre
group with positive gram stain's
had a higher odds of having antibiotic
prescriptions even if they had a
positive RVP so again clinical factors
play a role here typically have a
positive RTP doesn't prove that you
don't have a Bachelor infectious as well
so you have to look for both so the
sputum was positive they're more likely
to have antivirus prescribed even if
they had a positive RVP it is
appropriate here you can see the
reduction in antibiotic prescriptions in
the RVP only group
last study was that in patients
presenting with multimodal acute
exacerbation utilization of a
comprehensive IV p panel can
significantly decrease the rate of
antibiotic prescription that discharged
there's a huge economic burden of non
influence related viral infections most
is the most common illness in humans
about symmetry percent of surveyed
patients at at least one episode in the
previous year average of 2.5 episodes a
year most commonly Viner viruses adentro
viruses which produce about 500 million
episodes e'en nationally meeting
durations about seven point four days
resulting in twenty million lost work
days and 21 million lost school days
increased burden severity with asthma
and COPD and patient otitis media and
the annual cost was estimated in 2003 of
being about 40 billion annually a
significant burden
this is a state looking the distribution
of pathogens and pneumonia patients so
even in the ammonia patients that
initially were put into the studies they
had infiltrates as well as what I signs
and tendencies in pneumonia
subscrive the results came back even
then the distribution is significantly
higher higher for patients with viruses
the most common pathogens there with
Rhino virus and influenza A and B a then
came strep pneumonia and other bacterial
forms and then other viruses further
down so just to emphasize all
infiltrates they're not mean back to an
infection they can be produced by a
significant viral infection you have to
be on the lookout for both as the
pathogens in patient admitted with
pulmonary infiltrates and respiratory
symptoms suggestive pneumonia or lower
respiratory tract infection
this results in antibiotic misuse
inappropriate initiation prolonged use
when you're always concerned there could
be a bacteria which is treatable
compared to most viruses other influenza
which are not treatable with specific
antivirals resulting in about two
ministers and about 23,000 deaths a year
in the u.s. associated with
inappropriate use of antibiotics quite
significant
with bacterial testing is the cultures
can take two to three days perform and
get results back they have a low
sensitivity historically and faster more
accurate indicators of infection needed
needed to make critical antibiotic
decisions at the front end
percent of antibiotics prescribed for
acute versatran infection - probably
unnecessary based on the etiology after
the patient having viral infections
causes problem with misuses associated
with drug toxicity in Greece antibiotic
resistance and collateral damage
increased drug resistance infections
result in more serious illness or
disability high death rate for long
times recovery oftentimes for long
customizations we feel that if you have
an antibiotic and needs to be IV as we
know seven or more days which requires
that much more hospitalization are
sometimes unnecessarily and this is seen
in two most common syndromes of lower
respiratory tract infection and in
sepsis
you
we're used to using certain biomarkers
helping with the identify infection
sending pneumonia well with using strep
pneumonia and Legionella urinary
antigens we're using the influenza
enzyme absorbed assays immunoassays and
the polymerase chain reaction assay
which are now becoming more prevalent
more accurate and multi paneled we use
the MRA pcr nasal swab which has a low
positive predictive value at a very high
negative predictive value when you're
concerned about NMR sa pneumonia for a
healthcare-associated pneumonia and then
the multiplex panels viral panels allow
the detection multitude of viruses with
good accuracy and specificity and some
bacterial targets especially atypical
and those results can also come back
very quickly in one to two hours which
has really helped improve identification
and stratification of patients either
needing admission or appropriate
antibiotic therapy or not
does this study British a study out of
the UK looked at using the multiplex
Rossa Tory pointed care testing without
antibiotic stewardship so that's without
a really major educational program
coming into utilization of the testing
and surprisingly not surprisingly there
was no difference in antibiotic
initiation the front end but there were
more patients with a short course of
antibiotics or less imported out in
patients who had a positive point of
care testing seventeen percent versus
nine percent but the overall antibiotic
utilization was still very high but it
did result in a decrease length of stay
there was a rapid identification of
respiratory viruses yields the
opportunity for antibiotic avoidance
reduction in a necessary antibiotic use
has not been consistently observed
across studies especially for adult
patients when detecting viruses other
than influenza the main limitation of
current satori molecular thousands the
lack of bacterial targets the community
or hospital criterion is always thought
of maybe they have a bacterial infection
as well or their risk for that
you
this study bosses study out of the
Netherlands in Amsterdam looked at as a
large study looking at the rapid
molecular tests for influenza rescue
tourism Silvio virus and other asset or
viruses there's a systematic review of
the diagnostic accuracy and the clinical
impact of these studies so they were
either RSV alone influencing RSV
influential multiplex panels looking
using the diagnostic criteria the
cochrane methodology for diagnostic test
accuracy and subsequently for impact on
clinical care look at some 4,200 studies
and whittled it down to four diagnostic
testing accuracy fifty-six that is of
itself to be appropriate to be included
and about fifteen studies for impact of
the studies
you
accuracy was good the pooled sensitivity
of them ninety point nine percent full
specificity of the ninety six point one
percent across all different testing if
you had a test that was specifically
just influenza that had a high accuracy
flu plus RSV test was also very high in
accuracy the multiplex fire five studies
had a range of 89% and up but ninety
seven and nine percent sensitivity so
specific for the infections such as
influence at RSV it also had before
bacterial very typical that were present
on the panel they tend to be these
studies and be more accurate in children
that the viral load is higher and is er
yeah the benefits are reduced turnaround
time to less than three hours now which
results in the length of stay reduction
and increase appropriate use of or so
time of ear for influenza patients that
are identified early
you
the clinical impact signs 15 studies
December felt to be a program for
clinical impact with two respiratory
viral panel with PCT guidelines that is
their viral pathogen detection may not
necessarily attribute causation they
felt the rapid molecular testing of our
passage in detection proof provide
accurate results kiloton impact of rapid
diagnostic tests was somewhat
conflicting and but there was a high
quality evidence that rapid testing
might decrease the length of hospital
stay it might increase the appropriate
use of a so tomograph for influenza and
they suggested considering
implementation of rapid molecular tests
within hospital settings and recommended
performance of high quality randomized
studies to confirm their results
the bio sauna bio fire respiratory panel
menu to the common viruses did you see
there the most virulent being the
influenza viruses and RSV the parent
influenza researchers and to the virus
and then the for bacteria on the right
hand side Bordetella pertussis pertussis
comedian like a plasma under precautions
we've got the column they're looking at
different types of precautions that need
to be taken at the bedside air a is
airborne mast and vented room is
necessary C is contact hand-washing
gloves and mask Indians droplet so if
you don't know what the patient has and
they all have a relatively clear miracle
disease it's difficult to treat and then
you start getting staff getting affected
by the pins get infected puts the most
serious being influenza but all the
others do need some kind of isolation so
it's helpful to have that information
don't is a physician going from room to
room you don't want to catch even a
common cold when you're on rounds it's
kind of important to have that
information also it helps with
discharging patients quickly if it's
efed with common cold this is COPD with
influenza or RSV which are significant
more severe disease
you
the impact of early detection of
respiratory viruses this study looked at
the impact of early detection of virus
of respiratory viral infections by a
multiplex PCR essay on clinical outcomes
that our patients comparing outcomes for
adult patients with positive tests at a
tertiary care center across two
consecutive influenza seasons 2010 11
and 11 to 12 infections are diagnosed by
conventional methods in the first season
and by multiplex PCR in the second
season viral cultures have done
predominantly in the first season and
then those the flu PCR available then
but they found was the film or a
decreased the time to diagnosis of
influenza compared to conventional
methods one point seven verses seven
point seven hours p-value point zero one
five which is significant and the film
array also decreased the time to
diagnosis of non influenza viruses one
point five verses thirteen point five a
very significant p-value years is 0-1
this kidney impacts raising emergency
room it could be sent home Russ's rather
than being hospitalized and reduces
length of stay and admissions emissions
were reduced a length of service which
is not so significantly but still
reduced and duration antimicrobial use
is also reduced as with the number of
chest x-rays so they concluded that the
rapid turnaround with the rapid
turnaround time the multiplex nature of
the test allowed simultaneous detection
array of viruses and with the superior
sensitivity of film array may improve
the evaluation and management a patient
suspected of having respiratory viral
infections
section right to cover the use of
procalcitonin and combining
procalcitonin with a multiplex test to
help fine-tune your management in these
patients
the Vitis brahms ass may help guide
appropriate antibiotic use it's been
available since 2007 some FDA Class D
device has two previously cleared uses
in the USA one to aid in risk assess of
the substance septic shock on the first
day of IC admission and secondly to
determine the change in PCT level over
time by MIT admission which allows the
prognostication
the PCT protested as a host response
biomarker stimulated by bacterial
infection this is a precursor of
calcitonin helps regulate the
inflammatory response to bacterial
infection
it is normally produced by many tissues
but only the parathyroid gland tumors
procalcitonin calcitonin by the
breakdown in the interest under the
structures the normal protein levels are
less than 0.05
bacterial infections stimulate speedy
production in multiple organs outside of
the parathyroid gland and those can go
up significantly and can reach its ends
up to 40 but our range in our lab goes
up to 200 and if necessary we can tell
with that down further to get a higher
level when necessary
if you look at the chromatograph on the
right hand side thyroid cell being the
highest producer from the territories in
that region and all the other organs can
produce parent procalcitonin in the
setting-room bacteria
severe bacterial infection a PCT is
produced by numerous organism see Rises
within about 3 to 6 hours a flight to 20
to 24 hours and only identification
helps in risk assessment elevator there
was a highly suggestive of severe
vaginal infection
as you can see here from this cartoon
inflammatory response from viruses which
are interleukin-1 beta and TNF alpha so
a bacterial infections with your
interleukin gene of alpha produced it's
significant increase in cytoplasmic mRNA
which increases the Golgi apparatus
production procalcitonin which is then
released into the circulation if you
have a viral infection in the green the
bottom which is interferon gamma
mediated that produces no significant
acceleration of PCT production and so
there's no elevation in a viral
infection or procalcitonin in the normal
setting the in the parathyroid gland the
Golgi apparatus produces procaster and
it Cleaves interest only to produce
calcitonin but in the inflammatory state
when produced by bacterial infection you
see the uncle'd protestor and release
into the cytoplasm
this diagram PC that will go up
significantly after the second hour
following insult up to pretty high
levels and then starts to come down
predictably by 50% per day given the
half-life unless there's continued
infection or inflammation where the
levels stay high but if you have
adequate source control antibiotic
intervention the protoss and will start
to come down very predictably
the other biomarkers that interleukins
go up with information fairly quickly
and also come down and CRP is slow to
rise and slow to come down
this is typical PCD kinetics going up
with acute information infection and
then with appropriate antibiotic
intervention or removal of the source
the PCT that will start coming down
you
and here you see another classic diagram
of the PC levels coming down with
appropriate intervention in therapy and
usually you should see a good response
to the first probably this between day
two and day five usually a good response
to appropriate therapy if it's working
this is level ii
associated with spread of infection with
bacterial infection in this study
looking at levels with patients
presenting with respiratory tract
infection with a viral infection no
significant piece of the elevation for
the material co-infection the
significant elevation suggesting as a CO
infection
you
here we see PCB levels collating
severity where they present with simple
and sirs criteria EPS tested ancestors
aftershock is almost a linear increase
in the range of PCT elevation
and then the other very important thing
with PCT is a very strong negative
predictive value in these two studies
one confirming bacterial infection
second one need for antibiotics in a
lower stretch infection setting if you
have a negative procalcitonin one less
than 0.25 the need for antibiotics is
clearly reduced at the negative is about
92 percent and 94 percent respectively
in these two studies in those studies
when patients did not have Novation PCT
the need for antibiotics was not there
that's a critical biomarkers
affection agent assessing risk of the
specificity to bacterial infection
versus information alone rises rapidly
after Bachelor insult declines rapidly
with control of infection and has an
excellent correlation of severity of
illness
as we know when patients present with an
LRT a clinical characteristics are not
specific whether it's acute bronchitis
comunicate pneumonia acute exacerbation
the short suppressed cough sputum fever
of intense chills echo pain
we tend to characterize more viral
infections and bacterial but the other
things in the history which can help us
in family history or not such family
history but expose your history to other
people around you can help the clinical
characteristics are nonspecific and with
its ambiguity almost everybody got
antibiotics and as we've seen from the
previous data probably only fifty
percent of patients presenting with
these symptoms really need an antibiotic
get the piece of tea on presentation is
less than 0.1 or say less than 0.25 the
needs for antibiotics is discouraged or
strongly discouraged if it's less than
0.1 in the setting of a respiratory
tract infection
if the PCT level is above point two five
point two six or above with encourage if
it's above point five certainly strongly
encourage use of antibiotics this has to
be taken in context with the clinical
presentation of the patient if it's a
vision that looks septic that has a very
low initial level cleany is going to
give antibiotics same with
community-wide pneumonia presentation
but if the subsequent PC T's do not go
up and say less than point two five then
you got to think this isn't bacterial
maybe you should be looking for
something else and maybe not continue
antibiotics based on the current data as
you'll see
and the other important thing is Wendy
saw antibiotics usually when it's back
down from less than 0.25 or an 80%
reduction from a peak is when it's safe
to stuff antibiotics other than a couple
of situations where we know that longer
course antibiotics such as with
Pseudomonas onm RSA is indicated
regardless of the PCT
you
so this study salsa study was very
looking at COPD patients particular and
the appropriate use of antibiotics and
following a protocol as we saw with the
0.25 the cutoff level the appropriate
use of antibiotics in the initiation and
during the presentation of patients with
an acoustic West versus COPD some 280
patients were included and the primary
outcome was the antibiotic exposure at
the index exacerbation and the
subsequent antibiotic requirement for
CPT exacerbations within six months six
months follow up on these patients
secondary outcomes for clinical recovery
symptom scores length of authorization I
used a deaf lung function the
classification rates and titannics
exacerbation
the results showed that the index
exacerbation if you use PCT guidance or
antibiotic utilization there was a 40%
vs. 72% use of antibiotics based on the
algorithm and significant reduction in
antibiotic exposure relative risk
reduction of 0.56
PC guidance has the index exacerbation
allow for significant sustained
reduction to learn about exposure up to
six months vehicle outcomes and
improvements of 82 and 14 days and sick
lives did not differ between the two
groups and within six months
exacerbation rate was about the same the
authorization rate was about the same
time the next exacerbation was about the
same so reducing antibiotics by about
44% the absolute risk reduction by 31.5%
it not increase the rate of excessive
Asians or reauthorizations so that's
significant it is safe to do this using
this algorithm
as you can see here the actual reduction
in the procalcitonin group was
significant in the black bars and then
if you look at the amount of
the levels of pro calcium is similar in
both groups to help utilize this and in
the right-hand panel you can see the
exacerbations dosing of a difference in
the two groups and the reauthorization
recognition of a difference in the two
groups over six months
you
the conclusion of that study was that
PCT guidance for exacerbation of COPD
always a sustained advantage over
standard therapy and use in reducing
angelator cues for up to six months with
number needs a treat of three without an
increase in adverse events they're
pretty significant
next select look at this patient level
literature review and meta-analysis
current accordance with the Cochrane
Collaboration guidelines and the highest
form of clinical evidence by actually
utilizing data for individual studies
and putting them together you get
patient level data which produced
greater statistical power and more of us
findings than each individual study
there's some 990 records from the
Richard review of Estonian articles were
assessed for eligibility after exclusion
about 919 records looking at 6700
patients for 26 undergo trials in 12
countries mortality rate than 30 days is
significantly lower in p CT guided
patients that in control patients 9%
versus 10% in the controls the adjusted
odds ratio point eight three now on time
and if it was similar across subgroups
by settings and by tagging infection and
the pro cast setting guides also is
associated to point four day reduction
and granting exposure on average five
point seven versus 8.1 and the reduction
in antibody related side-effects 16
percent versus 22 percent
but the use of procaster guide
antibiotic treatment in patients with
respiratory infections reduces
antibiotic exposure and side-effects and
improves survival its widespread
implementation of programs and verticals
in patients acute respiratory infections
has the potential to improve antibiotic
management with positive effects on
clinical outcomes and on the current
threat of increasing antibiotic
multi-drug resistance
so when we when you review the data here
looking at baseline characteristics
effectiveness is the initiation
effectiveness and acrobatic curation
exposure and the safety there was a
common theme we're going to concentrate
on the COPD patients similar in both
groups
the effectiveness or initiation you can
see in this graphic here favoring PCT
that is reduced antibiotic exposure all
these studies including the scope study
at the bottom tamping PCT over control
production in initiation of antibiotics
or respiratory tract infection
significant reduction in antibiotic
initiation there and you can see 30
level findings for antibiotic initiation
and RTI favoring TCT and all of these
studies and then the effectiveness for
antibiotic duration and exposure
again on the study level from three
randomized controlled studies out of
that number and data from five RCTs that
the study love limitation level again
it's a given reduction in days at the
bottom meditation over five days versus
nine days and in the study level seven
days versus ten days favoring PCT
you can see here for acute bronchitis
there's a 65% reduction engine grinding
exposure in the PCT guided patients
versus control and you can see it for
acute exacerbations of COPD according
represent reduction exposure if you
follow the algorithm in the guideline
the safety similar no change and this
has been difference between sales in the
control group versus the PCT group we
look at this similar rates of mortality
in the RTA patient level Metro analysis
again favoring TCT complications of
deaths
I see admission hospitalizations Bristow
infections and recurrent or worsening a
section again similar length of stay you
can see and again for the acute
accessories as COPD today mortality I
chose a little lower in COPD group
the PCT can be added safely and
effectively and used for two additional
indications which came out in center of
2017 which is aiding decision-making and
antibiotic types of patients with or
suspected of lower confirmed respiratory
tract infections defined as
community-wide pneumonia acute
bronchitis an acute exacerbation of COPD
and an inpatient setting or emergency
setting and helped in pain to that
decision-making on antibiotic
discontinuation to patients with
suspected or confirmed sepsis this isn't
two additional indications as of
February 2017
you know this is also helps you
individualize patient care by measuring
each patients PCT and saying that this
patient does that does not identify so
it can be stopped at this point in time
that truly is personalized healthcare
for the patient and for each patient
inappropriate use of antibiotics exposes
patients to the risk of antibiotic
associated infection and production of
highly resistant infections and for the
healthcare system there's an overall
safety risk as we saw earlier with to
millions and 23,000 deaths from
inappropriate antibiotic use
city biomarkers can help guide effective
treatment decisions have been thoroughly
studied in case of suspected liti and
sepsis and associated with decreased
antibiotic use without worsening
clinical outcomes
provide data needed to make more
informed decisions an antibody
utilization at the front end and at
discontinuation but it has to be used in
context with clinical assessment and
management of the patient as well you
have to take the whole picture into
account the lab work as well as how the
patient looks and other data that is
available
and then finally combining the highly
complex with multiplex repertory panels
in PC T to optimize antibiotic
stewardship in these patients with COPD
so this study looked at discontinuation
rates associated with positive
respiratory viral pedal and low
procalcitonin results improvement of
suspected respiratory infections
patients required to have a respiratory
panel or Peacekeeper the first entry has
a presentation
drug order to evaluate the
discontinuation of antibiotic therapy
within 48 hours of procalcitonin less
than 0.25 and a positive viral
respiratory panel result or both
patience is similar in both grooves PCT
and respiratory viral panel the median
length of stay in the PCT less than 0.25
was four days for the positive attitude
around was only one day antibiotics
prescribed despite being a low PCT level
was about somebody consent but in the
positive RP panel alone was about 28% so
significant reduction in terms of
positive viral panel in the patients I
deposit positive tc+ PCT of less than
0.25 and a positive R palla for some
reason the antibody reaction was there
but not as much as with this the federal
panel alone it seemed that the positive
or negative or low PCT is to be ignored
is the common theme
31% antibiotics
72 hours viral panel only 28 percent and
then 61% when you have both data
elements available
so this is 4069 patients with t CT and
no receipt or a panel results mm 0ver
included ECG and RP panel testing was
obtained in 503 and 1823 patients
respectively with 295 patient's having
both results of these tests suggested
seminars 89 patients with potential
candidates for antibiotic avoidance of
which there were 219 with a PC less than
0.25 601 with a positive viral panel and
31 with both
antibiotics are administered for 307
patients in the first 72 hours with
discontinued at 48 hours of the party
availability
this is not suggested
a viral panel and loafie CT results are
in frequently associated discontinuation
of antibiotic therapy improvement
apostle resset ori inspections at our
institution direct interventions of
clinicians are likely needed the correct
this behavior decrease unnecessary
antibiotic use again this is when the
test was put out there but no real
formal education going out so it's very
important when you implement a new test
have appropriate education and guideline
and often a prompt in an institution we
had pharmacy calling up and saying that
you have a positive viral panelling have
a negative DC t consider discontinued
antibiotics if there's no other need to
happen like a year attract infection or
something else going on and over time it
took a few years wherever three to four
years the adherence to the guidelines
has improved significantly so we're
seeing that being implemented more
robustly now but it didn't happen
overnight
this study from branch and a ladder
Rochester again looked at serum Pro
calcitonin measurements and viral
testing to help antibiotic use for
respiratory infections in hospitals
patients randomized control trial again
looking at the winter season October
through April 2014
patients resigned one to one ratio
exceeds family care versus PC be guided
care with the highly multiplex PCR
testing primary outcomes and reading
exposure and safety assess at one and
three months
they found was there was a time wise
significant reduction in antibiotic
exposure when there was a low PCT trend
and the virus was positive and you can
see that the serum PCG levels are
similar in both groups
at 151 patients in intervention group
Isis identified in 42 percent of
patients and 83 percent of patients at
PG buys less than 0.25 again there was
no significant production difference
inactivated user adverse events between
intervention patients and there's none
intervention group the group analysis
did have a reveal to your subjects with
positive test for viral infection and
local values who had discharge receiving
antibiotics the a lot more patients were
started than probably needed to be at
the front end but there was a reduction
in antibiotics at the time of discharge
which is encouraging
shorter antibiotic directions along
algorithm and here interventions two
versus four days compared with
historical controls from the past six
versus four days
the low antibiotic use was similar to
our subgroup analysis of intervention
patients just their physicians responded
to viral and biomarker data and the same
could help design more future u.s.
studies and again key to implementation
is education and then experience an over
time patient that doctors seem to agree
that these tests are helpful and can
help reduce antibiotic exposure
to summarize
rapid diagnostic results are important
getting the result back in a timely
fashion within 2-3 hours really helps
improve the adherence to protocols and
guidelines Jeff the wait a day or two
anthrax already been started as people
often reluctant to stop at that point in
time the negative predictive value below
PCT combines with a strong positive
combined with a strong positive
predictive value of highly multiplex
respiratory panel has the potential
reducing antibiotic exposure
significantly results in less than two
hours improves compliance
real-time interventions improve results
and reduces length of stay and reduces
antibiotic costs
so that finishes the talk we'll
entertain some questions and just like
to review the questions and the answers
to the question that we had at the
beginning of the talk in terms of
starting the antibiotic thing most would
agree to start the antibody given the
data that they had and then stopping at
48 percent of jobs once the results were
back we tend to stop antibiotics at this
point in time with a positive viral
panel negative PCT but intentional how
many patient would have continued
antibiotics given that data thank you